oui à l'eau alors cyril la régie profite
de la présence de ce génial de cédric 6
heures ouais ou lui apporter son soutien
à ce soutien face aux faux culs qui lui
font face
non et oui vous pensez que la régie ne
savez pas tout non la régie surveille
tout elle a entendu des choses pas très
sympa vous avez des images
à son habitude la vue aux à son invitée
une question très simple la pression les
suspects ont qu à l'heure
[Musique]
c'était au début d'année après j'ai
vraiment chalard lady ya une semaine est
[Rires]
camille la phrase c'est pour ça que
cyril elle aime bien pas le temps passe
vite aussi vous avez le temps a passé 13
aces que je peux quand même dire quelque
chose bien sûr c'était au temps où jean
michel qui laisse boucle c'est comme si
max me traitait de puceau ça me plairait
bien quelqu'un qui m'a fait beaucoup de
peine c'est qu'elle y pense
non c'est inégal figé débuté cette
saison non parce que de la télé on a une
pendant le même barbier non il me fait
ça n'a rien derrière sa moustache et
longs 10
bravo